-I'm very excited.
You know I wrote --
I'm an author, right?
-Yeah. Oh, yes.
-So I've written "DADA."
-Yep.
-And that was...
-Huge.
-Well, yeah, it did well.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And I wanted my kid
to say "DADA" first.
But I have a new book
coming out.
-What?
-...just in time
for Mother's Day
that is going to flip the lid.
-You're gonna flip the script?
-It's gonna --
It's just amazing.
But I'm going to show it to you,
right?
Ready for this one?
-Whoa.
-[ Scoffs ] Dude,
this is my favorite one.
[ Drum roll ]
Now, what is it --
It comes out in two weeks.
It's not even out.
I just want to show it to you
for the first time.
-Right.
Little -- wet your beak.
Oh, snap!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"NANA."
-Oh!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Come on.
-It's a little...
-Yeah.
-It's a little water-worky.
-It's pretty cool.
It's awesome.
It's a love letter
to all the grandmas out there,
the -- the gammies,
the abuelas, the --
whatever
you call your grandma.
"NANA" -- It's just --
And it's -- This --
Honestly, this is the best one.
This is -- It's just beyond.
Look at the artwork.
-Wow.
-It's just so cute.
[ Audience awws ]
It's -- It's so cute.
It's just awesome, yeah.
I'm very, very proud of it.
Anyways, I'll talk more
about it, obviously, but...
I'm -- I wanted to show it
to you tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]